now like last time we had you on um I
talked about about your involvement in
big brother but looking back on it there
there wasn't any
real uh like discussion of how you found
big brother I wonder if like if there
was uh like a kind of um a synopsis of
like graduating high school in Tennessee
moving out to like what happened between
graduating high school and and finding
big
brother I I wasn't you know I moved out
to become an actor but and I'd taken
some classes and I went to the amican
American Academy of dramatic arts for
like six
weeks um but I was kind of
just spinning my
wheels and then my then girlfriend got
pregnant I'm like I I need to do
something and so friend of mine got me a
job writing for a couple of magazines I
started writing for magazines uh I lived
next door to an Antoine Fuqua the
director and he got me a he sent me to a
casting director who got me a commercial
agent so I was just had all these sticks
in the fire and one day I show up on the
set of a spike Jon
was helping Jake fogl Nest I guess he
was co-directing a video with Jake fogl
Nest uh for
wax and I remember it was the it it's
unfortunate but it was on the day the
Oklahoma City bomb bombing happened
because that was going people told me on
set and Jeff that's the first time I met
Jeff he was in the video and uh Jeff T
yeah yeah and
I told him I wrote he's like oh you got
to come by and check out the magazine
and I didn't even get to be in the video
I had to go to wait on tables you know
so I was like ah and and then I don't
know how much time passed before I went
down
to uh down south to see uh Jeff at was
World Industries okay it wasn't even at
Flint yet right and I walked around he
gave me a tour and I think it was a
little bit over a year or so or maybe
longer before I got the
idea maybe a couple years before I got
the idea to do the self-defense
equipment he was the only magazine that
would support me and helping me buy the
stun gun taser gun and because I had no
money I blew all the money I had my mom
gave me 300 bucks for Christmas and I
got the cheapest bulletproof V they had
and then I was sunk right so
I needed support from taine and he gave
it to me did you not um Pitch the
self-defense idea to like Howard Stern
and the talk shows and yeah yeah I I
faxed my idea to Howard
Stern and like pretty far and wide to
like everywhere that could possibly host
it oh yeah like I pitched it to details
magazine like everyone you can think of
and almost across the board people like
the idea but they kind of wanted to
treat it as a negative pickup they
didn't they like when you're done with
it bring it to us we can't be a part of
it until then and but I don't even think
I didn't hear back from Stern but much
later he goes I just thought you were
some nut you know which that's fair you
know around the same time I was pitching
to Howard Stern that I would come and
douse my entire body with rubbing
alcohol be set on fire and there in my
boxer shorts and and do back flips like
and uh I they didn't want that either
jeez would you imagine that
[__] what what kind of uh what kind of
Articles were you writing when you were
writing articles um I I like uh you know
I I love hunterz Thompson so a lot of
participatory journalism type stuff I'd
go somewhere or do something and write
about it in freelance you'd submit it to
different magazines all over yeah and as
you were writing you were getting
commercial gigs too right luckily I
started when my first year I started
auditioning for commercials full year
not one call
back and then my next year I got like 12
commercials and uh I didn't think you
did that
anymore it's just water bro oh
okay so yeah I was very lucky cuz I had
a kid then and and that that's how you
met Preston you guys were deliver like
uh cuz we were talking about you know
some of the worst jobs that you know
people had Preston I think had some of
the worst
jobs um one of his jobs he worked at a
uh waste disposal
place and there was a screen that caught
all the condoms and tampons and
everything and he had to squeegee that
screen that was his job oh my I'm like
you win Prest
did I did you not meet Preston on a
commercial audition it wasn't it was the
no
I I met Preston through friends I think
through Beautiful Jason oh yeah and
through that group is how I first met
Preston but when the show we were
getting the show for Jackass he was also
my then wife had a jewelry line and we
need people to like make the jewelry and
bag it and tag it and Preston was
sitting on the couch bagging and tagging
the jewelry along with myself and
whoever else we could find nice I'm like
hey you want to be on a show he's like
sure what came what came first Jackass
or the offer to do stunts on Saturday
Night Live um jackass came first and
right as we were getting ready
to go make the pilot cuz the deal took
forever took over a year for the deal to
get done for jackass what made it so
slow I don't know you have to talk to
the lawyers forever they're going to
have to have
the um
so but at the 11th
hour I got the offer from Saturday Night
Live and I went to the Beverly Hills
Hotel and met Lauren Michaels in the
Polo Lounge which incidentally is where
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas started
out Hunter as Thompson's novel so I'm it
was another connection to Hunter and God
it was it was you know I was going to
get 5 minutes on the show to do like a
stunt or a prank every
week and uh and for a guy who was
waiting tables and suddenly I I got this
pilot I'm about to shoot and then
Saturday Night Live wants me to do
something
and it was a lot you know because it's
like everything could fail I could make
the wrong decision but I just
thought God I'm just going to bet on
myself and my friends because on SNL I
would have been lucky to be on SNL but I
wouldn't have any control you know right
and you know and like jackass is big on
tone and if I'm not controlling the tone
along with you know Jeff Spike it's I
don't know I I just bet on myself and it
could have been a big failure I know we
tried our best but it succeeded yeah do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce fre your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and steo
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle of available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude